Why do I say Wednesdays and Fridays we
need to fast? Because the apostolic
churches
were
told, obviously by the apostles, to fast
Wednesdays and Fridays. Where do you
find that at? You
go to the Didache.
The Didache, the Ducky, however you want
to pronounce it. I don't know how you
guys want to pronounce it.
Didache, Didake. In fact, remind me, I'm
going to share Ash Mizes' excellent
video on Daniel 7.
And that the Son of Man is Messiah and
he's divine.
The way someone who is Jewish and knows
how to speak Hebrew pronounces the
Hebrew words
is so different from us who have to
learn how to pronounce it just by
reading the words as opposed to having a
teacher to teach us.
But nonetheless,
the Ducky, Didache,
if you go here in chapter 8
of the Didache,
in chapter 8 of the Didache,
here it is online.
The internal evidence internal evidence
of the document shows it was written in
the 4th century, perhaps 50 AD or
somewhere between 50 and 70 AD. There's
enough evidence in the document to show
it was written at the time of the
apostles and it was read by the churches
with the apostles' approval.
You with me now?
Why do I say this? Because this gives
you a window into the practices of the
churches, how they worship. In other
words, Didache is not
a manual on belief.
The technical term orthodoxy, sound
teaching.
It's a manual on practice, what they
call orthopraxy. It's telling you what
to do, what not to do. What righteous
deeds to cultivate, the sins to avoid.
And it tells you how to pray, what to
pray, how many times in a day do you
pray, how to get baptized, right?
What do you utter when you're baptizing?
It is a manual telling you how these
believers of the Lord Jesus Christ,
predominantly Jewish,
there's indication this is written to
Jewish believers with Gentiles, both
converted, how they prayed,
how they would fast, how they baptized.
It even condemns abortion and what they
call
pederasty,
Peter pederasty, pederasty, meaning
harming, molesting children.
It's all in this document.
You can read it less than an hour.
See right here?
>> [snorts]
>> You shall not commit murder, you shall
not commit adultery, you shall not
commit
pederasty.
I don't know how to pronounce this word.
There's some words I just cannot
pronounce. You shall not commit
fornication, the Lord Jesus have mercy
on us men. Forgive us, Father. Forgive
us, Lord Jesus. Forgive us, Holy Spirit.
You shall not steal, you shall not
practice magic,
>> [clears throat]
>> you shall not practice witchcraft, you
shall not murder a child by abortion nor
kill that which is begotten.
And you'll find
writer after writer, father after father
condemning abortion.
See?
Take you less than an hour to read it.
Okay?
Someone's manifesting, hold on.
Focus, guys.
>> [clears throat]
>> Hopefully I'm doing better than you,
brother.
Oh, you're a sister. Hopefully I'm doing
better than you, sister. You should let
me know. What's up, brother? How are
you?
Pray for divine I'm sorry, Reason
Believe. He came up with a very hard
video.
He needs you to bathe him in prayer.
Pray he gets to the priest and maybe the
priest does a prayer of cleansing. And
I'm going to show you his video.
He's here as one of my mods. He
converted to the Eastern Orthodox faith.
But here, we're not going to belabor the
point. We got By the way, about 3 hours
of teaching cuz I talked to Avery's on
the road. He's not going to do a live
today.
So I can be here till we go live with
Cameron. If you pray for my health,
holiness, the power of my throat
[clears throat]
to be strengthened by the spirit,
right?
To glorify Christ.
By the way, I forgot to tell you why I'm
buying McDonald's coffee.
Because when you have friends like
Vilard, the guy who gives out my
location, doxes me, who makes millions
of bucks and doesn't contribute a penny
to your ministry, you can only buy
coffee from McDonald's cuz it's two
bucks. You go to 7-Eleven, it's now
three bucks. Dude, I'm in full-time
ministry, all right?
Here you go.
Why do we fast Wednesdays and Fridays?
No, avoid Ron Wyatt. Ron Wyatt has been
exposed
that he was a fraud. Avoid him. Stop
going to Ron Wyatt.
Yes, get rid of them, Lord Jesus Christ
in this. Here you go. Chapter 8. But let
not your fast
be with the hypocrites. Matthew 6:16,
speaking of the Jews
who did not believe in Jesus. For they
fast on the second and fifth day of the
week. Second, that's Monday. Fifth day
is Thursday. Ironically, Muhammad who
wanted to appease the Jews would fast
Mondays and Thursdays.
So when do you fast?
But fast on the fourth day and the
preparation day.
Friday was known as the day of
preparation to prepare for Sabbath. This
is what leads me to assume
this is written to predominantly Jewish
believers. So, when do you fast?
When do you fast?
Yeah, it's three bucks, dude.
Fourth day, Wednesday and Friday.
Have you ever wondered why all the
ancient churches, and I also always used
to wonder, Assyrian Church,
Oriental Orthodox Church, Eastern
Orthodox Church,
Catholic Church, they all fast
Wednesdays and Fridays.
I never knew why. Now I know why.
Here it is in a first-century document
written to the churches at the time of
the apostles telling you the apostles
enjoin
fasting on Wednesdays and Fridays.
I don't know who Sean Ryan is, brother.
Please focus.
You got it there?
You guys see it?
Now, I've already mentioned this in the
past, but creature repetition, we need
to hear something repetitively.
Do you now see why
all the apostolic churches, churches
from
the time of the apostles, hold this in
common?
All of you folk fast on Wednesdays and
Fridays.
Where do you think it came from? Here it
is, the Didache.
It came from the apostles.
Sorry, my This is my allergies, this
stinking cat.
Now, why do you think these ancient
churches
will keep repeating the Lord's Prayer?
The Lord's Prayer.
Why?
Because this document written to the
churches when the apostles were alive
with their approval, that means this is
their teaching.
Says, "Neither pray as the hypocrites,
but as the Lord commanded in his gospel,
thus pray, Our Father, who art in
heaven,
hallowed be your name, your kingdom
come, your will be done,
as in heaven, so on earth. Give us today
our daily bread needful bread. Forgive
us our debt as we also forgive our
debtors. Bring us not in temptation, but
deliver us from the evil one.
For yours is the power and the glory
forever." How many times though?
You pray this three times a day, thrice.
Had I
encountered
priest who knew the ancient tradition
and the biblical and or apostolic basis
for these practices, it would have saved
me time.
Cuz I was wondering, why do you guys
constantly repeat the Lord's Prayer in
everything you do, like in a Bible
study? You see here why.
Making sense now?
The apostles enjoin saying the Lord's
Prayer three times a day.
Now, notice three times a day.
Why? One for the Father, one for the
Son, one for the Holy Spirit.
Now you see where you got fasting
Wednesdays and Fridays?
Don't fast like the Jews who rejected
Jesus Monday and Thursday, which
Muhammad adopted. You fast on Wednesday
and Friday.
Even baptism is covered.
Even
how to take the Eucharist and even
confessing your sins, chapter 14.
Right here, it's all covered. You
assemble on the Lord's Day, Sunday, and
you have to confess your sins before you
take your sacrifice.
It's all here, guys.
Now, interestingly, this also I learned.
I learned that because Catholics fast
Wednesdays and Fridays for meat,
that McDonald's then introduced a fish
sandwich for Catholics, cuz they don't
eat meat.
So, then McDonald's came up with the
bright idea, let's introduce a fish
sandwich, so the Catholic can come and
still eat fish and fries.
>> [laughter]
>> But, the way they fast back then, they
would fast from food, right?
But, nonetheless, here you go. Now, you
see
You see now
why you church And that's another thing,
Protestants. How do you explain the
churches in schism? Oriental Orthodox in
schism
with the Eastern Orthodox Catholic
Church, Syrian Church. Eastern Orthodox
schism with the Catholic Church.
And
the Syrian Church, all of these churches
are divided, starting in the
5th century, 400s.
Eastern Orthodox Catholics divided 1054.
Okay. How do you explain they all, every
one of them, enjoyed fasting on
Wednesdays and Fridays?
How do you explain that they all agree
to fast on Wednesdays and Fridays? Cuz
it came from the time of the apostles.
There you go.
Pray for me to get disciplined to love
Jesus perfectly. I don't love him
enough, not because I don't want to, cuz
my flesh is wicked. All right, so you
got it there, Rumble?
Now, let's go into the topic, shall we?